what's going on guys this is rob and
this video is sponsored by keeps so stay
tuned and in the next few minutes i will
tell you how keeps can benefit you but
before we do what is the topic of
today's video and what does this title
have to do with
anything going on right now right
because it seems like the theory of like
thanos and mutants and all that kind of
stuff it feels like it's old hat right
no and here's the reason why i think
this theory
is actually entirely possible now more
so than it ever was before to a degree
we could argue that maybe scarlet witch
had something to do with it i don't
necessarily think that's the case i
think that there have kind of been a
smattering of mutants that have appeared
over the course of the mcu's history a
few here a few there but not a number of
any real note instead i think there's
credence to this theory that it's
actually a combination of both that it's
basically the snap initiated by thanos
that blinked out half the life in the
universe and then brought all that back
that basically brought in mutants as
part of the equation but at the same
time i think it could have something to
do with scarlet witch and the idea of
them appearing here and there which kind
of makes sense right i mean we saw or at
least heard professor xavier in the
doctor strange 2 trailer and one of the
things that's interesting about
professor xavier right one of the things
interesting about professor xavier i
wonder if they're gonna have him
without any hair
right
you would think a man like professor
xavier would have hair by now but i
think i know why professor xavier
doesn't have any hair because professor
xavier is not using keeps yes let's talk
about our sponsor for a second see if
professor x had done what he was
supposed to ahead of time he never would
have lost those beautiful luscious locks
that he undoubtedly have but fortunately
for you you do not have to make the same
mistake so i don't know how many of you
are aware but two out of three guys will
experience hair loss by the time they're
35 years old which really concerns me
because i'm 37
[Music]
so i'm coming up on that point right
well the cool thing here is that with
keeps you can get quality expert care
without ever visiting a doctor's office
or a pharmacy and in fact with their
network of expert medical advisors and
prescribers and care specialists all
these folks that can help you out they
can make your hair goals a reality so if
you say hey i've got this just beautiful
throw this beautiful afro and i don't
want to lose it keeps can help you out
on that
not only that with 24 7 care every
treatment plan comes with a full year of
unlimited messaging so you can connect
with your doctor anytime you want to so
you can say hey dr bro
do you think thanos was right
was he right to blink out half the life
in the universe i can't necessarily
guarantee that your doctor will say yes
thanos was correct but
if you hit up your doctor
and ask them about your keeps treatment
plan i'm sure they can offer all kinds
of insight for you to help you reach
your goals so
hair loss stops with keeps to get 50
off your first order go to keeps.com
geek culture or click the link in the
description that's
dot com slash geek culture having said
that let's get back into our video so
again thank you to keeps for sponsoring
this video uh here's the thing right
in marvel comics and it's a super
obscure thing that you would only know
about if you've been reading long enough
it's something that's only ever been
referenced once well kind of twice the
there was the motivation behind why it
happened and then there was the results
of it happening right so there's two
things right the first one is uncanny
x-men a really x-men annual uh issue
number 11 and then there is operation
galactic storm these are really really
important when we talk about the idea of
the x-men just for reference i don't
believe we're going to be seeing
operation galactic storm in the marvel
cinematic universe and i don't think
we're going to see what's happening in
x-men or at least what did happen in
x-men annual number 11 in the marvel
cinematic universe but we can take that
concept and apply it and i will talk
about how so here's the thing in x-men
annual issue number 11 we were
introduced to something called the
crystal of ultimate vision now this was
basically an artifact that existed out
there in marvel comics that if you were
able to attain it it would quite
literally grant you ultimate knowledge
and ultimate power the thing about this
though is the crystal was finicky it
kind of had a mind of its own it could
decide who was worthy and who wasn't so
think of it as something akin to like
mjolnir right thor's hammer now the
thing about this is that if you were
deemed unworthy
by the crystal of ultimate vision maybe
your motivations were selfish or
whatever it decided deemed you as being
an unworthy person when you tried to
attain the crystal your entire
evolutionary race would be frozen it
would be stuck in place you would never
evolve you would never grow you would
never progress you would just be stuck
in that evolutionary state a really good
example of this is the cree race and in
fact it happened to the cree the idea
here is that the supreme intelligence
who you guys have seen in captain marvel
although you got kind of a piss-poor
explanation of what it is the supreme
intelligence is basically a kind of
conglomerate of the greatest minds to
ever exist both religious and scientific
as well as political in the history of
the cree empire they're all literally
hooked up to a supercomputer and that in
turn forms the supreme intelligence
which makes decisions and serves as more
of the political slash theological
leader of the cree race the idea of the
supreme intelligence is that it's always
trying to find a way to attain absolute
power so the cree can expand its sphere
of influence as any good empire tries to
do word had reached the ears of the
supreme intelligence regarding the
crystal of ultimate vision and a member
of the cree race was sent to attain it
that member of the crete failed the test
and it froze the cree race in their
evolutionary state meaning they never
progressed past how they look at that
particular point in time it's why the
cree never changed in appearance however
that was totally done and over with with
operation galactic storm so the idea
behind operation galactic storm is that
this was a war that was initiated
between the cree and the shiar it was
started by the cree and the shia
basically finished it but what the shiar
did for those of you guys who aren't
really familiar with that if you ever
played halo the shiar or like the
covenant from halo basically just like
an empire consisting of a bunch of
different races but the shiar had
basically detonated a bomb that was
colossal in scale and it wiped out
something like 95 like 90 to 95 percent
of the cree race just obliterated them
but what it did is it forced the cree
racist evolution to a to adjust right it
basically jumps out of their
evolutionary process and it sent them
into the process of evolving and that's
why following the events of operation
galactic storm if you ever read comics
then you suddenly started seeing
different colors of creep pink cree and
blue cree and green cree and so on and
so forth because their evolutionary
process had been jump started and they
were off to the races in terms of
becoming whatever their next stage was
going to be now taking this concept and
applying it to the marvel cinematic
universe there's evidence here right
there's evidence here that there can
simply be a circumstance whereby a
sudden jolt to the genealogy of any one
particular race across the cosmos could
basically
send them into the next state of
evolution right now what's really
interesting about this is that in marvel
comics there's no real explanation given
into why we saw this sudden
proliferation of the mutant population
in like the 30s 40s 50s and 60s going
forward as opposed to in years past when
you'd see a few here and a few there
right you get celine you get gideon you
get apocalypse right you get you know
gabriel shepherd and a few others here
and there some of whom are just
ridiculously powered and some of whom
can just kind of do some cool stuff
right but whatever the case is you just
kind of saw a smattering here and there
and then in marvel comics with again no
real explanation given suddenly in like
the 30s 40s 50s and 60s going forward it
was an explosion of the mutant
population right mutants were just being
born everywhere and there was no real
explanation as to why and there still
necessarily isn't right marvel's never
really bothered to answer that question
probably because nobody cares but the
point that i'm making is that you can
apply all this to the marvel cinematic
universe and you can say over the course
of the mcu's history by whatever manner
and whatever means that the x gene was
deposited into baseline humanity right
maybe it's like a failsafe by the
celestials in case like the deviants in
the eternals fail right maybe just part
of their experiment maybe it was just
the natural evolutionary process right
somebody somewhere was at some point
gonna be born with the ability to do
something special you know might as well
be that guy whatever the case is it
doesn't matter the thing is that like
mutants were occasionally born and then
what we got is that instead of like the
30s 40s 50s and 60s there was this
proliferation of the mutant population
that you guys are right that what had
happened is in the aftermath of the
thanos snap right half the life of the
universe being blinked out of existence
and then suddenly coming back it
literally jolted the entirety of the
genealogy of the human race and every
other race that exists out there this
can bring in a wide array of
possibilities because now it's not just
humans who have their x genes activated
maybe it's like the scrolls right so now
you get like deviant scrolls and you get
dire wraiths and you get like eternal
scrolls different things like that right
maybe it's cree so on and so forth but
you start seeing these mutants popping
up or at least mutants among their own
races popping up but specifically with
regards to earth suddenly that's how
people with abilities come into
existence one thing to keep in mind here
is that not a lot of time has passed
between the end of avengers in game and
what's going on in the mcu right now so
it's very very easy to believe there are
people out there who are developing
abilities and for any number of reasons
we simply just don't really know about
them sword was talking about that in one
division right people are popping up
with powers and they don't really know
how to explain it it was easy to let it
slip under the radar it was easy to not
notice but it's entirely possible that
what we're talking about is that you
guys are absolutely right when you say
that in the aftermath of avengers
in-game thanos snapping his fingers
wiping out all you know half the life in
the universe in infinity war and that
life suddenly coming back because of the
incredible hulk jolted the genealogy of
humanity and any other races that
existed out there and basically
jump-started their evolutionary process
so now mutants are being born the real
question you have to ask here is how did
the x-gene get there conventional wisdom
and comic book knowledge would tell us
the celestials were the ones who did it
i don't necessarily know if that's the
case maybe it is maybe it's not real
question you have to ask is why would
they do that in the first place i mean
at the end of the day the celestials
basically experimented on pretty much
all these different races across the
universe of marvel comics
because they could i mean that's
literally the answer you get right like
these celestials experimented on people
and basically created like deviants and
eternals and mutants for no other reason
the fact that they could they were
curious to see whether or not these
experiments would work and thank god
franklin richards was born on earth
because if he hadn't the fourth host
would have wiped everybody out so it's
just different things along those lines
right let's just
those weird little things franklin
richards is kind of like the end result
of the celestial's experiments hence the
reason why he's this little kid that can
alter reality on a universal scale he's
like a universal constant it's stupid
how powerful he is but nonetheless right
let me know what you guys think you know
i happen to think about this and i know
that in previous videos i'd like shut
that down i was like there's no way
that's just kind of silly kind of
ridiculous but giving it some thought
there's a lot of credibility here and
there's evidence to back up this claim
so let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section thank you all
for watching and make sure you guys
check out keeps and i will catch you all
later
peace